what's up guys I'm so freaking excited
for this video here yet under control
please this is an important video today
I'm doing a collab with V Emma
Chamberland okay if you don't know who I
am a Chamber Lynn is she basically just
blew up in here and is completely
crushing it on YouTube so yeah I'm super
excited wherever there she's hilarious
everybody loves her she's a she's a
pretty big deal you want to record the
video it's mom yes I was so nervous I
feel like I I don't know I want it to be
a good video she's very funny and I feel
like I'm gonna just sit there and not
have anything to say alright you know
what Eric your confident manifest ish
I'm Eric [ __ ] Tuvok also I'm
gonna be editing like Emma because you
guys are here for him so
before we do anything I want to show you
about to be exclusive and my Chamberland
BuzzFeed review right now a camión it's
doing it should I be should I be
sensitive totally honest definitely men
in black vibes worried about it might
die here so cute this is definitely my
cat at home miss you Oliver this is like
the most like La Vie news oh yeah this
is spectacular I'm not even gonna make a
joke about it it's really great this
might be those Instagram of a place I've
ever seen in my life are you ready for
this I might have to Instagram her I
always Emma's Instagram is on fire she
gets like 1 million likes on every
single picture it's just 3 million
followers this is the secret to
Instagram this how you do it I feel
uncomfortable ok got yours all around
there's like I have like one friend in
my life we're like I can take photos and
not do like visibly uncomfortable
commentary about it because taking
photos is not something that's not
awkward it's all alright snacks I'm
pretty exact yes
[Music]
funny story I used to watch those in
class cheese instead of a chicken breast
instead of one what's your takeaways
about BuzzFeed good snacks good coffee
good almond milk Instagram situation
unmatch okay so
emma is here in New York because you're
like a fashion girl now just given with
a clothing line so apparently now I am a
respected fashion guru and if I'm not
invited to Fashion Week next year
there's gonna be issues and I will be
suing fashion is like not really that
hard I feel like if you just throw
things on like and you pull it off
anybody
I honestly believe that if you have a
good personality confidence is key the
king is wrong having a good personality
being a good person that only gets you
so far in life if you have a fire fit if
you can do both you dominate the world I
don't know here's what I want to do I
want to challenge you to a thrift store
challenge down and prove to you that
anyone can thrift I'm down I mean we'll
see what happens here I mean I'm not
gonna shut you down but I'm also worried
concerned and good luck rules of the
game me and you going head to head to
try to pick out the best fancy outfit we
possibly can what do you win absolutely
nothing not a thing literally nothing
all right so let's go through let's go
thrifting all right so we're at the
thrift store this is Goodwill curated
whatever I don't know what curated means
but it's like a good thrift store yeah
how much time do we have I think we have
15 minutes 15 minutes 15 1 5 good luck
let's go here's my game plan I'm just
gonna pretend like I know what I'm doing
I don't what I'm gonna talk like I do so
we're trying to find like a cool stylish
red carpet outfit purple imagine like
just bold what if I go super bold with
this I feel like my game plan is to go
so crazy that people think it's style
are these gold sneakers don't these look
like shorts that just keep going Wow
have you ever seen anything like this um
so I have to pick something out for me
which is stressful because I can tell
they don't have any gowns we're not are
you creative Oh imagine me of this that
ain't it
my nipple will pop through it but that's
extra likes are they wonderful
this is eighth grade graduation dance I
don't need the commentary on that you
can just do imagination with that one it
looks like something that like a mermaid
would wear in a movie when it's like
they finally like get legs and then
they're like come on land and they're
like there's a decent chance that he
will win because I'm so sorry but I
think on a suit is easy that's a no
who's that teddy bear with an umbrella
who walks around some sort of like
cartoon you know what I'm talking about
planning to Paddington going with a
Paddington looks like this yes yes yeah
yes now I just need pants right all I
need is pants
where are pants
mom Oh which pants he just calls mom
listen to him
getting all the freaking advice from her
as if no did he leave these fans here
hey don't touch my pants what stop it
don't make me second-guess myself really
so uh I'm tearing out stop it I know is
that even here's I might have you I
don't I actually don't
oh I guess it's time mine didn't vibrate
yet
well mine did well okay screw it you
know what I'm right ain't no one's gonna
get in my head okay not Emma not my mom
you gotta believe in yourself okay you
gotta just beat you
[Music]
no my bad why is it not that bad I'm so
mad hitting a ceiling better what did I
say though if you're bold if you're bold
you commit to crazy looks
[Music]
sorry I can't hear him when he's saying
cuz I don't care because I'm about to go
ride horses tasting good with shoppers
grabbing the competition going on in our
store for BuzzFeed video so anybody in
the Seoul has any insight on fashion and
style it would love to hear from you it
is to one I've won and that's that
that's the team he won honestly well
those are about it's better but I mean
what's in my heart is you think they'll
feel better yeah so for a first-time
shopper and thrist I'm gonna be pretty
good I did good
you actually genuine it and you know why
because I watch print thrift store
videos oh my god that's actually really
great you guys go check it out him and I
tell it is me
alright have a good one a bird a life
David watch DubLi bop bop David arrived
baby hey unsolved is on a new channel
subscribe here